this week barack obama has put on
shining display his meticulous character
assessment capabilities by nominating
Sonia Sotomayor to become a new Supreme
Court judge of course such inconceivably
dumb Republicans led in a charge by the
overgrown repulsively simple-minded Rush
Limbaugh FL to need to point out what
they consider obvious infirmities in
regards to her qualifications perhaps
they're simply trying to point the
finger today their attention from their
obvious own shortcomings in the boudoir
here to comment is the abhorrently
conservative pj TV commentator steven
crowder Wow well there's a way to
welcome your guests there Keith so
please tell me mr. Crowder explain how
you justify your absolute disdain for
this woman who is so clearly a minority
sir right well I'm gonna try and act
like that wasn't a completely loaded
question to begin with uh the truth is I
don't like her as a judge because of her
principles and her policies really it's
it's among the first to point out sir
that you're in this position towards
miss Sotomayor is obviously a product of
your ethnocentrism that literally has
nothing to do with it Keith mr. Crowder
you've already disqualified this lady in
the very bowels of your soul exclusively
because she is a different color from
yourself is it so wrong to have somebody
in a position of authority in this
country who may not fit into this
fantasy of a white suburbia and it so
badly crystallized your worldview is it
so repugnant as for you mr. Crowder for
an impoverished latina descent and to
enjoy the higher positions of government
that your white counterparts so
fervently take for granted
yes mr. Crowder Vicki I can might be a
different color than yours but if you
hurt her does she not feel honor is your
view of people of color so askew then
you abridge an inhuman like disconnect
from the very heart that beats in your
chest I stand before you today sir a
[ __ ] to tell you that she is not an
animal not a beast here for your sick
conservatively warped mind to enjoy not
a circus act
prancing across the perverted landscape
of your mind for your personal
satisfaction but a human me here to
comment on the matter is MSNBC's own
Rachel Maddow well I agree with you
Keith you're so smart Thank You Rachel
we
mr. Crowder one more time why is it so
wrong for her to have a flame of passion
for justice that you and your white
colleagues share why must you make
constant attempts to snuff that flame
leaving nothing but a smoking wick but
mr. Crowder it is all for naught because
her flame will continue to grow even in
the midst of your Republican hurricane
it will flicker through the storm and
continue to shine with the brightness
that will act as a beacon for the whole
world to see right well I got maybe 20%
of what you just said I get that you're
implying I'm a racist
aye aye there's no implication necessary
sir you have already sunk your own ship
on this one here is a picture of you at
a clans meeting only weeks ago is there
no end to your hate mr. Crowder yeah
that that's clearly a photoshopped
picture there can how dare you question
my journalistic integrity sir I wear
power suits power suits no really if you
look at that picture I think you can see
George Clooney in the foreground that
actually might have been taken from a
Coen brother how dare you implicate such
a fine American as George Clooney in the
quagmire that is your racist Republican
agenda
you disgust me mr. Crowder which is why
you are today's worst person in the
world
that's lovely I would wish you a good
day but that would be far too kind for
what your lordly hateful pre deserves so
I will bid you at you you're the bane of
my existence Keith w-t yeah
you
you